Chancellor Merkel hosted the Portuguese
Prime Minister pedro passos coelho on
Tuesday but Portugal's economic recovery
took second place this visit was
overshadowed by events in Moscow method
said Vladimir Putin signing of the
treaty to make Crimea part of Russia
violated international law but she also
stressed there could still be a
political solution to the crisis Vivian
and bleak of default regarding the
events in Ukraine will focus on dialogue
and on talks as well as the sanctions
that have already been imposed it's in
all fish play sets the tone was much
harsher in London the British government
has suspended bilateral military
cooperation with Russia and warned of
more to come Russia should be clear
about the long-term consequences and in
the United Kingdom we will not shy away
from those consequences events in Crimea
have rattled nerves in Eastern Europe US
Vice President Joe Biden met with the
polish Prime Minister in a show of
support for the NATO ally the United
States and Poland stand shoulder to
shoulder in vital missions around the
world but recent events remind us that
the bedrock of our alliance remains
collective self-defense president Obama
has called for a g7 summit next week to
discuss the Crimea crisis the meeting
will focus on what further steps may be
taken against Russia